vamos a las noticias de la economía
actualizadas con Juan Pablo lucumí Juan
Pablo saludo para usted nuevamente
estamos para actualizar las noticias así
es y vamos a comenzar esta vez por
América Latina porque el fmi ha elogiado
la solidez de la economía colombiana y
también aplaudió su ruta de crecimiento
Así es abro comillas dijo una
trayectoria de crecimiento más
sostenible así dijo Esto fue lo que
exactamente dijo el fondo monetario
internacional acerca de Colombia en su
informe anual sobre la situación del
país cuando pues visitó este país en el
mes pasado en febrero Perdón en el
informe se lee lo siguiente abro
comillas los riesgos a la baja
prevalecen y son elevados pero los
fundamentos económicos las políticas y
los marcos de las políticas de Colombia
son sumamente sólidos y apuntan a la
resiliencia del país también añadió que
el crecimiento de la economía colombiana
en 2022 fue uno de los más dinámicos
entre las economías emergentes pese a la
inflación esto no informe que salió ayer
Eso era lo que trataba de decir minutos
Estas son las conclusiones del organismo
internacional luego de su visita al país
cuando recomendó que siguiera las
políticas monetarias constructivas o sea
aumentando las tasas de interés para
reducir la inflación algo de lo cual el
presidente Gustavo Petro constantemente
ha dicho que pues se niega algo que
parece también estar fallando o todavía
no ha dado los resultados porque la
inflación sigue al alza Y eso es lo que
vemos a continuación en este gráfico con
una inflación interanual del 13,28 por
ciento esto la última el último dato y
también que las tasas de interés siguen
aumentando pero la inflación no cede
bueno Juan Pablo que no le fue muy bien
fue al Líbano es un caso bien diferente
y el FM y sigue preocupado aún por la
crisis en ese país Ángela un panorama
completamente opuesto al de Colombia
porque pues el organismo dijo que en
términos generales pues la misión en el
Líbano mostró algo de decepción por los
pocos avances que ha tenido el país para
implementar las políticas que el
organismo le pidió para poder acceder a
un plan de rescate por 3 millones de
dólares desde virus la capital el jefe
de la misión del fmi en Líbano Ernesto
Rigo dijo que los avances de la Reforma
van muy lento escuchemos
ha habido algunos avances pero
desafortunadamente tal como habíamos
dicho antes en septiembre El Progreso es
muy lento teniendo en cuenta lo
complicada que es la situación el país
está básicamente en una crisis
importante uno hubiera esperado mucho
más en términos de implementación en
términos de aprobación de legislación
que es necesaria para avanzar vamos a
cambiar de tema y vamos ahora a hablar
de algunas de las reacciones de China
después de la audiencia que sucedió en
el congreso de Estados Unidos este
jueves con el de tiktok Así es Ángela
Pues fue la portavoz del Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de China la que
hoy respondió a las acusaciones de los
congresistas estadounidenses en las que
afirmaron que la empresa china tiktok
recopila datos de personas en el
extranjero Esto fue lo que ella dijo
quiero enfatizar que el gobierno chino
da gran importancia la protección de la
privacidad y seguridad de los datos de
acuerdo con la ley nunca ha requerido y
no requerirá que las empresas o
individuos recopilen o entreguen datos
ubicados en un país extranjero de forma
que Viole la ley local sin embargo en el
centro de toda esta discusión están los
temores de occidente por una ley China
de 2017 que exige a las empresas de ese
país entregar datos personales al Estado
si son relevantes para la seguridad
nacional el consejero delegado de la
aplicación que se sometió ayer al
interrogatorio tuvo que reconocer que
algunos datos personales de los
estadounidenses Todavía están sujetos a
la ley china pero insistió en que esto
cambiará muy pronto sin embargo
recordemos que la tasa la Casa Blanca la
comisión europea Canadá Reino Unido y
más reciente una noticia de Francia ya
han prohibido a sus funcionarios de
gobierno el uso de tiktok en los
dispositivos profesionales
Juan Pablo en otros temas pasamos a
Europa porque sorpresivamente le fue
bien a la economía de la zona euro
Ángela superó todas las expectativas y
previsiones se trata del dato de
crecimiento económico de los países que
comparten la eurocopamoneda que alcanzó
un máximo de en 10 meses según el índice
de producción es amplio global conocido
como El pmi el dato estuvo por encima de
la marca del de los 50 puntos que es
justo ahí donde se separa la diferencia
entre el crecimiento y la contracción
económica como podemos ver en marzo o
este mes fue el 54,1 muy por encima de
la de febrero y también muy por encima
de la previsión que habían hecho
agencias de noticias como routers del
51,9 y que pues esperemos afecte hoy los
mercados y también hay indicadores Así
es precisamente vamos a hablar de las
bolsas europeas que siguen operando en
su mayoría en números rojos pese a este
dato que acabamos de dar los indicadores
de Alemania Reino Unido y París tuvieron
pérdida superiores al 1% en Asia las
bolsas cerraron ayer también con
pérdidas luego de conocerse el dato de
inflación de Japón que aunque fue menor
del mes anterior con el 31, ciento
interanual todavía está muy por encima
de la meta del Banco Central Juan Pablo
su cifra del día son dos coma cinco
millones de agentes
de función pública de esta de Francia
los que en este momento tienen la
prohibición de descargar tiktok y
Netflix esta era el dato que le decía
que se unen con parte de Reino Unido
Estados Unidos y bueno más que se van a
unir para la prohibición pues Juan Pablo
el agradecimiento para usted le deseo
que tenga un feliz fin de semana y nos
veremos pues Próximamente espero yo
Próximamente Muchas gracias